once
the uk had a small diagnostics industry
now it's doing coronavirus tests in the
millions
this is the part of it you don't often
hear about
the cyclists and drivers shifting
hundreds of thousands of swabs
every day but are they getting the
protection they need
we were heading to drive throughs
picking up bin bags of covered
putting them in containers that we
weren't cleaning very often
alex a member of the freelance workers
union
used to deliver tests to and from this
building
home of the doctor's laboratory one of
the biggest testing companies in the uk
it has lucrative testing contracts for
major sporting
and retail bodies but behind the scenes
not everything was as it should be i've
got hold of a leaked copy
of an investigation by the health and
safety executive
entered the doctor's laboratory and it's
a thick document but the message is here
on the first page it concludes
i have identified contraventions of
health and safety law the issues raised
by the remote inspection
which was carried out in may at the
height of the pandemic
included crowding couriers into small
spaces
and advice to clean sample transport
containers
at least once a week when it should
really be
at least once a day would you clean your
hands once a week
you know after you've touched something
you clean your hands
after the samples have been in the box
and taken out you clean the box
it's a routine sort of procedure you
know over cleaning isn't the problem
under cleaning definitely can be
the doctor's laboratory told us it had
fixed all the problems
but that at the height of the pandemic
the guidance was changing daily if not
hourly the spokesperson said despite
superhuman efforts by our safety team to
implement these at speed
not every detail was captured and the
points for improvement to our safety
systems
highlighted by hsc were fully accepted
and implemented immediately but the
finding raises questions about the
burden placed
on the fragile gig economy we uncovered
this scene
captured by cctv outside a care home in
the northeast
the driver takes the box of tests puts
it in his back seat
then discards the box putting the tests
and himself at risk the company told us
it took health and safety very seriously
but a senior mp
said it raised questions about the
security of gig economy workers
if you're worried about what you're
finding don't hesitate
ring the hsc helpline make sure
they know what you're worried about and
i want to make sure the hsc can respond
effectively every time that happens
a message for everyone but especially
those on the front line ronald manthal
sky news